TKACHUK.
10 POINTS INEHIND
LINE.
AND PATRIK LAINE HAS THE PUCK
AND IT'S TWO SHIFTS N PAST THE
STICK OF DEAN KUKAN,
IT.
MONAHAN TAKES THE FEED, WALKS TO
THE NET AND THE SHORT ON N.
LUCIC TRIES TO SQUEEZE THROUGH
ALONG THERE BY LAINE, RIGHT
THROUGH THE GOAL MOUTH.
HERE'S
>> Jody: WELL, BIG SEQUENCE
THERE DOWN AROUND MARKSTROM TO
TOP OF THE RIGHT CIRCLE.
ELVIS MOVES LATERAL
♪
>> Jeff: ANOTHER STOP, ABLE
BJORKSTRAND, VORACEK FULL
STRIDE.
GETS IT BACK AND DEFLECTS IT. U
GAVRIKOV, NOW A LONG STRETCH
PASS, IN, DU THAT ALLOWS ELVIS
MERZLIKINS TO STANDRNS THAT ONE
PUSH IN AROUND THE BLUE PAINT,
BUT THE BLUE JACKET
TWO-MAN ADVANTAGE.
ONE-TIMER HERE AND
OVER HIS PAD IN FRONT, NET, AND
SOMEHOW MARKSTROM ABLE TO MAKE
THE BLOCKED.
BJORKSTRAND AND JENNER BOTH TRY
TO GET TO THE PUCK.
LAINE, AND  IT'S 2-0  STRAIGHT
STICK BLADE, BOY, THAT IS CLOSE.
THE PUCK IS TID THERE
RIGHT AT THE END.
AND THIS WAS JUST AFTER A PRETTY
GOOD SHIFTIN, TKACHUK SCORES.
ON A 2 ON DOES,FRONT, AND -- PA
BACK.
IT'S NOT D FROM VORACEK,
LOOKING TO CUT S JAKE VORACEK
OVER THERE, BACKHAND PASS.
BEAUTIFUL DRAW WON BY THE FLAME
GUDBRANSON WASTED LITTLE TIME
INTO THE NET, JUST WE'VE
SEEN A FEW OF THOSE TONIGHT.
LUCIC.OT GOOD PACE ON
THEY ALL BUY IN.
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE THEY ARE.
HERE'S MONAHANIPPED BY VORACEK
BUT MONAHAN COLLECTS IT WITH
THAT PUCK.
>> Jeff: OH, GREAT SAVE THERE.
THE HALLWAY HERE.
>> Jef